we're out of work what does this mean
unemployment insurance will it cover the
bills
there's isolation this fear of the
unknown there's misinformation you put
it all together it is very disorienting
to say the least
if you're feeling disoriented it's not
you it's everyone and it's everywhere
and it's it's with good cause today is
Saturday you know how I know today is
Saturday because my lawn clock said
Saturday when I woke up this morning but
if you drive around it doesn't seem like
Saturday right Saturday's the day that
people are off work except people were
off work yesterday Saturday's the day
that the traffic is lighter but the
traffic was lighter yesterday so it's
literally one day blending into the
other and just as a matter of
perspective a matter of context does
this feel like it feels like it's been
going on forever
but it really hasn't New York State had
its first case of CO bid just 27 days
ago New York schools closed only 10 days
ago the New Rochelle cluster which was
the highest cluster in the United States
which thanks to the good work of our
Health Department has now come down that
was 18 days ago when we started the
school closings in New Rochelle and we
started the testing and the drive
throughs the overall shutdown of
non-essential workers was only eight
days ago feels like a lifetime
perspective well how long does this go
on how long do we expect it China which
was the first test case right first case
was 12 weeks ago that's when it started
in China South Korea started nine weeks
ago Italy about eight weeks ago so Oh
keep it all in perspective there
this disorienting time where one day is
just blurring into the next a lot of
people ask me why is this so much talked
about but ventilators I never heard
about a ventilator before you're not
alone I never really heard about a
ventilator before either but every
emergency situation is unique and every
emergency situation winds up focusing on
an issue that you would have never
thought of before we've been through
emergency situations superstorm sandy we
needed 1,000 portable generators
immediately who have heard of needing
1,000 portable generators we had
flooding in the northern part of the
state we need 700 miles of sandbags who
ever heard of needing 700 miles of
sandbags so there's always a particular
circumstance that winds up developing in
these situations that really you could
never anticipate and in this situation
it is about a ventilator why because the
majority of these patients they're not
coming in needing surgery you know it's
all the same it's a respiratory illness
their lungs are damaged they're having
trouble breathing they have a cough and
they all need a ventilator and that is
the peculiarity of this situation
compounding it is usually when we equip
a healthcare system people are usually
on a ventilator for three or four days
with kovat patients there are on for 11
to 21 days that then compounds the
ventilator issue not only do you need
more but people are on them longer so
you need even more and that increases
the problem I think the president
was right to use the defense production
act but the defense production act
basically says is I'm not going to ask
private companies to help out and it's
great that we have volunteerism etc but
the defense production Act gives the
federal government significant leverage
to actually say I need these produce and
I need these produced by X days now the
federal government still pays they pay
an increased cost for the accelerated
production but it gives the federal
government the ability to do that and
when it comes to ventilators they are
the necessity in this situation what do
I do as governor basically I ask people
who know I ask the experts a lot of
questions and just staying on the
ventilators well what if what if what if
what if we can't get the ventilators
what do we do if we don't have enough
ventilators then you use bag-valve-mask
s-- what is a bag valve mask this is a
bag valve mask this is what you do if
you have a person who needs a ventilator
and you don't have a ventilator the way
this works is it's basically a manual
ventilator and someone squeezes the
ventilator the bag continuously this
looks easy I guarantee if you do this
for any length of time you see how
difficult it winds up being this is the
alternative if you don't have the
ventilator we are actually buying these
we've bought about 3,000 we've ordered
about an additional 4,000 of these bag
valve
masks we're even talking about training
National Guard people team learn how to
operate this device which is relatively
simple to operate but you need a lot of
people to operate this 24 hours a day
for each patient right so those are bad
valve masks they're the alternative to
ventilators and in short answer is no
thank you if we have to turn to this
device on any large scale basis that is
not an acceptable situation so we go
back to finding the ventilators because
we need the ventilators well you need
30,000 ventilators do you really need
30,000 ventilators look I'm not a
medical expert even the medical experts
can't tell you what you're going to need
here at the high point they do numerical
projections and then you plan based on
the projection you plan based on the
data based on the science based on the
numbers the data says at that high point
of need you could need 140,000 hospital
beds and you could need 30,000
ventilators that's what the numerical
projections say so we're planning for
that quote-unquote worst-case scenario
which the models predict maybe we never
get there
maybe we flatten the curve and we slow
the infection rate so we never get to
that point and that's what we're trying
to do and we're working on that day and
night but if we can't flatten the curve
you can't slow the infection rate you
hit that apex make sure you're ready for
the apex and that's where the 30,000
ventilators come in I have no desire to
procure more ventilators than we need on
a very practical
basis the state is buying most of the
ventilators the ventilators cost between
25,000 to 45,000 dollars each so they're
very expensive and you're talking about
a state government that frankly is
already in a from a position of revenues
in a terrible position because we're not
collecting any revenues literally so I
don't want to buy any more ventilators
than we need to buy on a very parochial
basis I don't want to pay for them and
after this is over we'll have a great
stock pile of ventilators whatever we do
but the state has no interest in
inflating the number of ventilators that
we actually need something interesting
about the price of entha lighters when
we started buying them they were about
$25,000 now they're about $45,000 why
because they're in such demand and
they're such competition to buy the
ventilators which I'll touch in a moment
the governor has sent the government has
sent us four thousand ventilators those
four thousand ventilators are not
currently in use why because we don't
need them currently what we're doing is
we're planning for that apex we're
planning for the critical need and
making sure we have the equipment the
staff the beds for that critical need
we're not at that critical need where
projections change but the models say
you're 14 to 21 days away from that apex
we call it when that curve hits the
highest point but when that curve hits
the highest point it is too late to try
to acquire what you need acquire what
you need now that's the concept of
putting together a stockpile and that's
the process we're going through now we
only have 14 to 21 days so it's not a
significant amount of time but do
everything you can to get ready now
there's an old expression you go to war
with what you have not with what you
need which is true when the bell goes
off and you have to go to war you deal
with what you have because it's too late
to do the preparation the but on that is
until you're in that situation do
everything you can do to be prepared for
it right if they tell you you're going
to go to war and 14 to 21 days then
spend the next 14 to 21 days getting
ready everything that you would need
when you actually have to go to war for
us the the war would fully engage if and
when we hit that apex and that's why
everything we're doing now is in
anticipation of that flatten the curve
so the apex never happens god forbid the
apex happens make sure we have as much
of the equipment staff etc that we would
need for that moment a few updates they
still forecast the apex to be 14 to 21
days again that changes on the modeling
every time the caseload goes up or down
a little bit that affects the
calculation on the apex what do you need
at the apex 140,000 beds
that's hospital beds dormitory beds
we're working on that every day and
we're getting closer and closer to that
140,000 number PPE equipment right now
we have enough PPE in stock and all the
local health systems say they have
enough PPE in stock short-term nobody
has enough long-term so we're still
buying and we're still talking to the
federal government about acquiring more
PPE
there is a concern among healthcare
professionals because the CDC guidelines
suggest a different product
call for PPE and masks depending on the
condition and apparently there is a
crisis set of guidelines for that the
CDC puts out for how many gown how often
you change it down how often you change
your mask etc in a crisis and the CDC
has put those crisis guidelines in place
and many health care professionals are
concerned that those guidelines do not
adequately protect the nurses and the
doctors in the healthcare staff that are
that are working on this issue dr.
Zucker is looking at that if we believe
the CDC guidelines don't protect health
care professionals then we will put our
own guidelines in place you have a bed
you have the equipment you need the
staff and that's where we're working on
bringing more reserve staff and putting
that reserve staffing capacity in place
and that's going very well and then back
to our favorite our ventilator quest
word to the local health systems we need
the local health systems to think more
holistically in other words you'll have
a Regional Health System western New
York Central New York New York City and
they'll have a number of hospitals you
can have a single hospital get
overwhelmed within that system you can
have the staff get overwhelmed you can
have one hospital where they run low on
supplies the local health systems have
to change their orientation where it's
not hospital by hospital which is the
normal culture every hospital is
freestanding on its own and is its own
entity and buys its own equipment has
its own staff etc I need the local
health systems to change their
orientation and operate and
as if that system is one if you see a
local hospital getting overwhelmed shift
to an adjoining hospital both within the
public system and the private system you
have public hospitals and then you have
private hospitals voluntary hospitals we
have to stop operating as individual
hospitals and they have to operate as a
system and I need the local officials to
do that so patients can and should be
moved among those local hospitals as the
need requires staff can and should be
moved among those local hospitals as
circumstances require State Department
of Health has not only advised that but
has mandated that it's not the normal
operating culture but it is a necessity
in this situation because depending on
where a hospital is you'll have
hospitals getting overwhelmed because
they'll happen to be in an area where
there are not a lot of other hospitals
or because that's a hot zone cluster
zone that Hospital gets overwhelmed all
right shift cooperate plan as a local
health system the may come a point where
the state steps in and actually
allocates among local health systems
this is what I said the other day you
may have patients from downstate New
York being moved to upstate New York why
because if the entire local health
system in downstate New York gets
overwhelmed or the local health system
on Long Island gets overwhelmed and the
Long Island Health System says to me
look we've allocated we have eight
hospitals we have allocated everything
we can among our eight hospitals with
still overwhelmed well then we'll shift
the burden literally to a different
health system and I just want them to
anticipate that and see that that's
coming we have asked the pharmacies to
cooperate above and beyond here and to
do free home delivery their long lines
at pharmacies right now that's not good
for anyone I'm going to be speaking with
some of the major pharmacy chains today
to ask if they would be cooperative but
this would be a very big benefit I
understand it's a hardship on the
pharmacies to provide home delivery I'm
asking them to do it free of charge but
it will make a very big difference also
the Department of Health is monitoring
the density and activity in the New York
City Parks specifically on the
playgrounds this has been a problem we
spoke about it last week
the New York City Mayor DeBlasio and the
speaker Cory Johnson have spoken to this
they gave us a plan we accepted the plan
the plan is premise on the fact that
people will reduce the density in
playgrounds no basketball no contact
sport social distancing there have been
reports that that is not happening and
it's not in compliance speaker Johnson
has made this point and I bitterly
believe he's right so if the density
compliance is not working on a voluntary
basis we could get to a point where we
will close those playgrounds so I again
ask the people in New York City
especially young people please take this
seriously for yourself and for others
and let's do it on a voluntary basis
we're also now administering 1,100 tests
of the hydroxychloroquine and the
zithromax this is the prescription that
the president has been very optimistic
about we hope to be optimistic also but
we're now using it on a large scale
basis for
particularly in the new york city
hospitals and we'll be getting results
soon Javits will open Monday I was there
yesterday it's a 1,000 bed emergency
hospital it is amazing what the Army
Corps of Engineers did in a short time
it was about one week and the progress
they made is really extraordinary and I
want to thank them from the bottom of my
heart the Army Corps of Engineers the
National Guard which is our work force
that we call out in all these situations
I've worked with many of them and I know
them after so many situations together
but they showed up and they've really
done a great job and this should open on
Monday the USNS comfort is going to be
on its way as of today I'm told the
president is going to be seeing it off
it should be here on Monday that will
bring 1,000 beds it also brings medical
personnel which frankly are more
important than the beds in this case and
it has operating rooms etc we'll use
this to backfill and take pressure off a
hospital so a hospital can backfill onto
this 1,000 bed facility I'm hope it gets
here Monday and I will greet it with
open arms I spoke to the president this
morning actually just before I came in
today I apologize for being a few
minutes late and the president approved
for new sites for emergency medical
facilities one in Brooklyn at the Port
Authority cruise ship terminal it's
called one in Queens at Aqueduct
Racetrack one on Staten Island and one
in the Bronx at the New York Expo Center
I went and toured these sites yesterday
they are perfect well perfect none of
this is perfect they are appropriate and
suitable to bring in large scale medical
facilities that one
thousand square feet 120,000 square feet
they're open they have electric they
have climate control etc so this is
going to be a big advantage it's just
going to be a will add another four
thousand beds and there's one in every
borough in New York City which was
important to me every borough knows that
they have a facility and they're getting
the same treatment that everyone else is
getting I'm a New York City outer
borough person you don't know that
classification unless you're from New
York City they're how the borough Queens
Brooklyn Staten Island Bronx those are
outer boroughs Manhattan is the inner
barrel but they never call it an inner
borough
everyone is being treated the same we're
adding to that bed capacity to get to
the 140,000 beds we've added 695
additional beds South Beach Beach
Psychiatric Center on Staten Island
which is opening up we have the
Westchester square Bronx 200 beds Health
Alliance in Ulster County 235 beds so
you see again we're trying to have
facilities all around the geographic
location that's experiencing the
increase we're also making another shift
where we're going to go to Co vid only
hospitals where people in those
hospitals will just have the kovat virus
so the staff that is there is basically
working with one type of issue as
opposed to a normal hospital setting
where you can have people with heart
ailments and other medical issues and on
top of them the kovat patients the
health commissioner has given us good
advice it's it's smarter to keep the co
vid patients separate you don't want a
person who goes into a hospital with one
situation developing kovat because they
happen to be exposed so this is smart
and we're going to isolate 600 beds for
just this treatment
South Beach again Westchester square and
SUNY Downstate which is in Brooklyn this
will shows you the coverage that will
have when all of this is said and done
and you'll see it's equally distributed
and it's significant and in truth many
locations have been constructed adapted
modified and it's been done in a very
short period of time again all this in
contemplation of the apex if we're lucky
the apex never happens the New York
State Department of Health has gotten
approval by the FDA to start a new test
which is an antibody test where we can
test individuals to see if they were in
fact infected by the virus resolved and
now have the antibodies so they have an
immunity to the virus this has been
being done here it's managed by our
Health Department the FDA has given us
approval Department of Health is working
with private hospitals to actually enact
this now so this is happening now and
this it could be a big big breakthrough
if that happens on the theory of risk
reward we're supposed to have a
presidential primary election that's
coming up on April 28th I don't think
it's wise to be bringing a lot of people
to one location to vote a lot of people
touching one doorknob a lot of people
touching one pen whatever you call the
new device on the ballots so we are
going to delay that and link it to an
election that was previously scheduled
on June 23rd the June 23rd date is for
state legislative races and
congressional races will move the
presidential election to that date
ironically I had advocated that it be on
that date all along anyway so there's
only one election and people only need
to come out once everybody wants to vote
everybody was this do their civic duty
but don't make me come out and vote you
know 11 times put the elections together
so I can go to the ballot once and this
will actually do that we are also
extending the tax filing deadline to
July 15th this is good news for
individuals for businesses you don't
have to file your state tax return your
file it with the federal tax return on
July 15th it's bad news for the state of
New York on our parochial level that
means we receive no revenue coming in
until July 15th this is the increase in
the trajectory of the number of cases
you see it goes up again
the number of people tested we tested
17,000 people yesterday again we're
testing more than any state in the
country and more than China and Korea of
a tested total test that is up to one
hundred and fifty five thousand number
of new cases 76 81 you see the state
getting more and more covered just a
handful of counties that have not
reported any positive tests this is the
summary 52,000 people tested 7,000
currently hospitalized 1700 ICU patients
2700 patients discharged that's up 681
remember people go into the hospital
people get treated people leave remember
most people never go into the hospital
eighty percent they self resolved most
impacted states
the state of New York fifty-two thousand
next is our neighbor New Jersey eight
thousand then California four thousand
but you see the reports nationwide that
other states are finding it other cities
are finding it I believe you want to see
more and more of that but again in
comparison you take California 4,000
cases
compare that to the situation we're in
with 52,000 cases people say I advocate
for more help for New York with the
federal government and I ask for more
things than other states are asking for
yes
respond to the need respond to the need
we have 52,000 cases
California has 4,000 cases I want
California to have all the help they
need but I want to make sure the
distribution of need is proportionate to
the number of cases if you're looking
for a good news today on the numbers the
number watchers this is good news
I wouldn't put tremendous stock in it
but it's good news we're watching the
trend right because we're trying to
gauge when and if there's an apex the
number of daily ICU admissions which are
the critical point for us ICU admissions
means people who need ventilators
ventilators are what's in short supply
the ICU admissions went down only 172
compared to 370 for the day before you
see the overall line is still up the 374
was very troubling troubling because
that was a gigantic leap the 172 may be
a correction from the 374 I don't like
to look at the data on any one night we
average three or four nights to get a
more consistent track but this is good
news on a one day number the number of
ICU admissions dropped as did the number
of new hospitalizations dropped so
there's a correlation there that also
affirms both right it affirms the ICU
number affirms the new hospitalization
number but again I wouldn't put any - I
would
put too much stock in any one number you
see the overall trend is still up but
you could argue that the trend is
slowing I say don't argue follow the
numbers get more numbers whatever the
numbers say the numbers drive the policy
so we'll track it every day and we'll
see where we go the worst news in the
news that is most depressing to me and
I'm sure every New Yorker number of
deaths is up to seven hundred and twenty
eight of that 728 what's happening is
people are on ventilators longer you saw
that every average length of stay on a
ventilator the longer you are on a
ventilator the less chance you are
coming off that ventilator that has
always been true it's more dramatic in
this situation since this has been going
on a period of time you're having more
and more people now who were on
ventilators for a longer and longer
period of time and those are the people
we are losing they tend to be people who
came in with underlying illnesses
underlying respiratory illnesses
compromised immune system not all of
them but most of them but that doesn't
make it feel any better right these are
still people who we lost we lost because
of this virus if they didn't have this
virus they would be with us today so I
don't accept the concept of well these
were people who were old and death is
inevitable yes death is inevitable for
all of us just not today right that's
the point again total perspective this
is not a new situation it's not just New
York it's not just the United States
this started in China they have all the
data since China
and you have a very broad database to
call from again on perspective don't
forget the basics
I know people feel this has been going
on for so long wash your hands washing
your hands by the way is just as
effective health care professionals will
tell you as hand sanitizer so wash your
hands don't touch your face I'm a big
face touch sure for some reason my own
face stay six feet away from people the
social distancing is important and don't
get complacent these rules are not just
important in the beginning you have to
do this every day so you have to stay
disciplined about it general comment as
to where we are rule 1 in any almost any
situation in life certainly in
government certainly in an emergency
situation is to plan forward plan
forward plan the next step
don't be reactive be proactive don't
wait to find out what the virus is going
to do to you anticipate what's going to
happen and plan for the step ahead we
have been behind this virus from day one
we have been in a reactive posture from
day one with this virus we're waiting to
see what the virus does and then we're
responding
the virus makes another move and then we
respond no you don't win on duck defense
you win on offense you have to get ahead
of this anticipate what's going to
happen and and create that reality now
that's what we're doing with the apex
preparation right we don't have that
crisis today we could have that crisis
in 14 to 21 days so yes I'm creating a
stockpile to
day for a possible reality 14 to 21 days
from now I'm not going to wait for day
13 to say oh my gosh we need 30,000
ventilators it's over
so get ahead of it that's our apex
preparation plan but beyond just New
York as a nation we have to start to get
ahead of this in two areas specifically
on purchasing you can't have a situation
where 50 states are competing with each
other to buy the same material that is
what is happening now when I showed you
the price of ventilators went from
$25,000 to 45,000 why because we bid
25,000 California says I'll give you
30,000 Illinois says I'll give you
35,000 Florida says I'll give you 40,000
we're literally beating up the prices
ourselves now every state no one's doing
anything wrong I'm here to protect New
York that's what I get paid to do I have
to acquire the ventilators I have to pay
whatever I have to pay to acquire the
ventilators I don't mean to take them
from other states but when you have a
system where you say to the states okay
you go out and buy what you need to buy
we all need to buy the same thing we all
need to buy PPE we all need to buy n95
masks we all need to buy ventilators so
we're all shopping the same distributors
the same group and it's not even legally
price gouging I was Attorney General I
don't even think you have a price
gouging case this is just private market
competition
my daughter car is working on the
purchasing team they change the prices
you can see the prices going up
literally during the course of the day
so if the federal government organized
this if the states organized among them
because you can't have the states
competing against the states and then by
the way when the federal government goes
out to buy the same equipment for their
stockpile now it's 50 states competing
up against the states and the federal
government competing against the states
so this is not the way to do business
we need a nationwide buying consortium
either the federal government should say
I'll be the purchasing agent for the
nation and others I will distribute by
need or the states which is hard to
organize 50 states a vice chairman of
the National Governors Association I'm
going to talk to them about this
maybe the states could come up with a
voluntary buying consortium and then we
distribute by need but this is something
that has to be worked out not just for
this but for the future because this
can't happen again also we have to plan
forward on testing we mobilized we've
scrambled but this is still not where it
needs to be we need many more tests
there are still people who can't get
tests and we need tests that are faster
there are other countries that are
developing faster tests developing home
tests we have a rigorous approval
process through the FDA and CDC in this
country it served us well in normal
circumstances these are not normal
circumstances I would say to the market
if you have a test and a home test and a
state wants to take responsibility for
monitoring the results of the test god
bless you because you can't have a
situation where you have a five-day
waiting period for a test that's five
days for the person to be out there and
possibly infecting other people and if
the goal is to open up the economy as
quickly as you can you're going to need
a much faster testing process to find
out who had the antibodies which means
they had the virus in resolve and whose
negative and who's boss
so you you are going to need a much
faster testing process that's the only
way you get the economy up and running
in any relatively short period of time I
showed you those I'll end where I closed
I'll end where I began you saw the
number of days that this has been going
on only 28 days schools closed only ten
days feels like a lifetime this is not a
sprint my friends this is a marathon you
have to gauge yourself you have to
understand that this is going to be a
long-term situation and even though it's
so disruptive and so abrupt and so
shocking it's also long-term and each of
us has to do our own part to adjust to
it it is a new reality it's a shocking
new reality there is no easy answer
we're all working our way through it and
we all have to figure out a way to get
through it
my gratuitous two cents see if you can't
find a silver lining in all of this
people say extraordinary things to me
that I just pick up anecdotally I was
going for a walk yesterday with one of
my daughters and captain captain is my
dog and people come up with all these
interesting ideas you know who's
painting their house because they never
had time to paint their house before
who's working on a project that they
never got to who's reading a book that
they never got to do who's writing a
book few people say I'm writing my
journals I'm writing my life story you
know find a way you have the advantage
of time here and you have the advantage
of time for communication I've had
conversations with my daughters
our hours long conversations where it's
just us just us talking no place to go
she doesn't have to go to work
she doesn't have to run out and they're
priceless they are priceless I'll never
get the opportunity in life to do that
again you know we're gonna get through
this and they're gonna go off and find
the boyfriend and then do whatever they
do I've had conversations with my mother
we can't leave the house and she's in
the house and so we sort of take turns
talking to mom and talk to my mother for
hours and it's special it's special so
yes it's terrible and I'm not trying to
say it's not a terrible circumstance but
even in a terrible circumstance if you
look hard enough you can find the little
raise a few rays of light and people are
doing it and I think we all should it's
going to be a marathon but we're going
to get through it and we will get
through it and we are going to be the
better for it when we get through it we
will have learned a lot we will have
changed will be different but I believe
net will be different in a positive way
tell me questions comments you have
Connecticut New Jersey said so in a
White House remarks today he said also
that you had spoken to him about this I
spoke to the president about the ship
coming up and the four sites I didn't
speak to him about any quarantine
conversations I don't even know what
that means you said yesterday that what
are what can they do to prepare for that
I've given that at this point April 5th
well look all of the projections on the
apex are just that are projections April
5th is earlier than our state projection
so dr. Zucker will will get with the
local health commissioner there to have
that conversation but this operates in
two levels first you have a local health
system so mayor de Blasio has runs a
very large public health system and then
you have voluntary hospitals private
hospitals us call them all those
hospitals have to be planned and
operating is one system one Hospital
gets overwhelmed which we've seen in New
York City you have to immediately from a
management point of view be able to use
the surrounding hospitals for support so
one system get one hospital get stressed
shift shift to the other hospitals one
staff get stressed shift to the other
hospitals when I was saying before this
is not how they think it's not how they
manage it's not how they plan and it's
not take any analogies school districts
right
every school operate every school
district operates
like an isolated entity there's no
thought that maybe this school district
would have to cooperate with the
neighboring school district
yeah well the hospitals have to and each
local health system has to do that
because you will have hospitals
overwhelmed now if within that hospital
system you want to maximize all of your
potential you still are over capacity
then the state can help with additional
capacity either by one of two ways
shift shift some of those patients to
less occupied health systems our health
systems upstate New York right now are
not as occupied as the downstate ones so
either shift among health systems or
start to use the additional capacity
that we've been creating in that
locality I don't even know what that
what that means I don't know how that
could be legally enforceable and from a
medical point of view I don't know what
you would be accomplishing but I can
tell you I just I don't even like the
sound of it not even understanding what
it is that has been lifted the
quarantine for those individuals and the
CDC's recommendations have been that
after for those who are positive after
70
is they don't have symptoms after 72
within the period of 72 hours then they
can be not inquired to voted against the
people who tested positive until they
pass the second test is that at the
guidance as I've mentioned is that seven
days after positive seven days 72 hours
without symptoms this is why it's
dangerous to answer a question until you
actually know what the person said
mandatory quarantine if if you're
talking about what we did in New
Rochelle that means a person in that
area must remain in that home if they're
in their home or in mandatory quarantine
if they meet a certain protocol right we
never said you can't travel outside of
New Rochelle we never said there was any
geographic boundary to New Rochelle you
know if you said I want to go quarantine
in my girlfriend's house in the Hudson
Valley all right but you have to be
quarantined so we never said any
Geographic constraints right mandatory
guide and Ettore quarantine is a scary
concept because it sounds like you're
saying to people you can't leave this
district we never did that I'm sorry
Justin there is stopping police car
stopping cars with New York plates to
stop people from New York coming to
Earth stay I have heard that I don't
know any details about that I don't know
if anyone does does anyone know about
this morning we're gonna reach out to
Gina Raimondo as office after this but I
haven't heard other than the news
reports and look you're getting a lot of
sensational news reports now so you know
everything with a grain of salt
sometimes two grains of salt
no can a doesn't mean I don't like them
and I wouldn't like to be on the phone
with them but this morning and I am
wearing we're in constant communication
governor for those of you who can't hear
the question governor Lamont is the
Connecticut governor will quote the
bigger fish than me you know last
fishing outing governor Murphy is the
New Jersey Governor where in cooperation
we're coordinating like no states have
ever coordinated before but I was poking
with him this morning can the common
cold throw off the swab test and can the
common cold throw off the swab test
become reckless change so the common
cold is a corona virus but each corona
virus has its own sort of fingerprint so
it won't throw it off common cold does
not throw off this rock test I have it
on expert we have not had we've been
watching that very closely
Rob do you know we have right now we're
still getting the applications come in
we'll look at that as the applications
come in but right now we're not
suspending the requirements but we just
we just started the in-person
requirements were really able to do that
online or be able to do if I thought
what appeared to be cuts to public
hospitals at a time of coronavirus can
you comment on that public hospitals are
all hospitals these visa vie the
Medicaid redesign team there appear to
be cuts of somewhere and ballpark of 400
million dollars the the places that are
getting the most funding now because of
what the federal government did are the
hospitals right the hospitals receive
significant funds quote-unquote for the
corona virus but the corona
expenses you can basically equate to
anything now in the hospital system so
the hospitals are getting more fun than
than almost any other area that the
state budget covers how much of the
hospital is getting do you remember Rob
100 billion hundred billion dollars
national yeah look we have no money
right so life is options the state has
no money but if you're getting the
federal bill had 100 billion dollars for
hospitals for coronavirus related
expenses they are doing better than
anyone else
you know we're gonna move all of the
elections to jail yeah we haven't had
that conversation hospitals are required
to have birthing partners in the room
with individuals those I'm sorry who
said that Howard so we had we had issued
guidance back on March 21st advising
hospitals that they should allow at
least one person in the delivery room
when people are giving birth and some of
the hospitals were ignoring that
yesterday we updated that guidance to
make it a directive so that women do not
have to be alone while they're giving
birth and we're gonna reinforce that in
an executive order they should allow one
person in the revenant Publix besides
the person giving birth we can't the way
they wrote the law we can't
so as you're negotiating the budget now
you're not spending any of that civilian
dog can't do what you can't do
we can't that's the way they wrote the
bill I told them 157 times
metaphorically but that's the way they
wrote the bill I believe you said that
the state would needs 40,000 ventilators
today it seemed to be 30,000 is that is
that a change or are we've acquired some
it's because you're a partner the
projections aren't showing no that's of
Annie no thank you
nobody's contacted me this contact ESD
the Empire State Development Corporation
and they can make Appeals and they're
being considered on a case-by-case basis
with an eye towards public health Empire
State Development said contact the
Empire State Development Corporation
Eric Gertler who is the head of that and
ESD is making the exceptions we can go
back and check with the ESD and find out
if they've made any exceptions
specifically no maximum capacity one
hundred forty thousand beds now what's
interesting here is which sounds
daunting but in this case you know
you're not doing an operation per se
you're not doing open-heart surgery
you're not doing a lot of these are
people who have almost the identical
problem which is a respiratory long
issue and that's why on one hand it's
relatively it's simpler to set up a
temporary Hospital because you're
dealing with the same symptoms over and
over the compounding problem is they all
need those ventilators to grant clemency
to release people who might be nearing
the end of their
in prison do you intend on taking other
steps we're looking at that now we're
looking at exactly that now when do you
when you intend on having any sort of
decision on that we're actively looking
at it
governor this may be wishful thinking
but but have you put any thought to what
sort of benchmarks what's tested
statistics would you have to see on the
backside of the apex to start to lift
restrictions to start to ease some of
these executive orders that you put out
or are you as you're thinking gotten
that far yet no short answer is no right
I'm we're focused on the apex we're
coming up the mountain we're focused at
the on the point of the mountain because
that's our critical point your question
Jesse which is a good one is if you get
on the other side of the mountain
what kind of drop are you looking for
before you would say we're open for
business we have not calculated that I
think before you get there you could get
to a broad distribution of a test a home
test a faster test so it wouldn't just
be the drop in the number of new cases I
think the real reform the real
innovation here could be get those home
tests that other countries are starting
to use and let people test themselves
well the CV test is easier than the
antibody test the antibody test you have
to go in and you have to have blood
drawn the CV test they have cv tests
that are at home tests and I think you
you could get to a point where you say
and some of them are relatively
inexpensive do the test you're new to
your negative go to work period and
divorce it from the trajectory of new
cases if you actually had the testing
capacity and that's what I would be
focused on also I said to the FDA give
me the ability myself to go out and seek
New York State to go out and seek new
tests home tests will test them we have
200 laboratories
we'll do the clinical trials and let's
see if they're right because you want to
start the economy and I understand the
rush to start the economy and everybody
gets the concept but the new tests I
think are the fastest way to get there
doctor do you want to come in I think
you covered all that the key point is
that that and the antibodies to measure
as the governor said is a blood test and
it's important to recognize that that's
different than a test for the Khurana
parts okay let's take one more anyone
who didn't ask there was no one who
didn't ask a question it's a nice look I
don't know how you raise taxes on people
who are out of work and their business
is closed
because government needs more funding I
don't know how you do that now we lost
we lost another nurse yesterday you know
the Jessie am i shocked no these people
put themselves in extraordinary danger
and we're all talking about isolation
and precaution and we're all wiping
every doorknob and then you have people
who every morning get up and go out and
deal with the unknown talk about losing
control totally uncontrollable these
nurses the first responders they are
just so extraordinary to me as people
forget everything else and these are not
high paid people it's not that they're
doing it for the money it's not that
they don't have families they are just
extraordinary and they prove a time and
time again but I've never seen a
situation like this where their heroism
is so obvious and the risk is so obvious
and their public service just rises
above
I mean it's I am in awe of what they do
and I find that inspiring I'll tell you
the truth every time I say well you know
what I'm feeling tired I'm feeling this
I forget me I'm not doing a third of
what these people are doing so god bless
and thank God for them and I'm sorry for
their loss ok guys thanks same thing
keep the same strategy and move that
strategy with